in 1970 Tom Dempsey
of the New Orleans Saints attempted the
impossible a 63-yard field goal
I hit it sweet Dempsey said setting an
NFL record that would stand for more
than four decades born without most
fingers on his right hand or toes on his
right foot
Dempsey played 11 seasons in the league
his special shoe now in the Pro Football
Hall of Fame Tom Dempsey was 73 Li
Fierro had just a few brief scenes in
the 1975 film jaws but one was
unforgettable
chief roadie yes the film was shot on
the Massachusetts island of Martha's
Vineyard where Fierro worked for more
than 40 years at the island theater
workshop teaching well over a thousand
kids Lee's mark on the island is
indelible the workshops Kevin Ryan said
Lee Fierro was 91 David Driscoll is a
modern-day dream keeper professor David
Driscoll was a champion of
african-american art awarded the
National Humanities medal by President
Clinton in 2000 Prisco was an acclaimed
artist himself as a curator collector
and professor at the University of
Maryland he pushed for black art to be
seen as American art David Driscoll was
88 best-selling writer Patricia Bosworth
wrote acclaimed biographies of
Montgomery Clift Marlon Brando and Jane
Fonda and started as an actress herself
appearing on Broadway and opposite
Audrey Hepburn in the 1959 film the nuns
story I'm not taking my vows I'm leaving
Patricia Bosworth was 86
I've been playing at the el cheapo Tyvek
since January of 1980 Freddy Rodriguez
senior was the heart and soul of
Denver's jazz scene a regular at clubs
like el Chapultepec where he played up
until last month son Freddy jr. was one
of his bandmates
his wife Tina he met 75 years ago jazz
he said is a projection of what you are
Freddy Rodriguez senior was 89 Nick jazz
Danone was a deputy tech editor with The
Associated Press you might have seen him
in a Pease tech test videos you might
still need your passcode during
Halloween jazz Danone was an avid
adventurer and ran marathons on every
continent he always helped his fellow
runners if they were in distress said
his cousin and he tirelessly helped
young ap writers improve their pieces
nick says Damon was 51
freida Oh gran was a nurse educator and
former head nurse at Jacobi Medical
Center in the Bronx New York as the
corona virus spread she posted this
picture on Facebook writing I can't stay
home I'm a health care worker four days
later she was admitted to the hospital
Joseph her husband of 30 years said they
came from Ghana together and both became
nurses she's my everything he said my
wife friend my adviser Freda Oh cram was
50
oliver stokes jr. was better known in
new orleans as go DJ black and milds he
worked the clubs and brought new orleans
bounce music to his radio show a father
of four stokes coached football at a
charter school he would literally give
you the last dollar in his pocket his
wife Cassandra says he died four days
shy of their second wedding anniversary
Oliver Stokes jr. was 44